Berlin Spandau sozialer Wohnungsbau aus
den 70ern
20.000 Menschen leben hier
Lokalpolitiker Lars leschewitz hört von
allen gerade die gleichen Sorgen was
wird aus den günstigen Mieten wenn der
Status der Sozialwohnung kippt damals
hieß es man so viel wie man verdient ein
Drittel davon darf die Miete nur sein
geht ja gar nicht mehr so viel kann man
gar nicht verdienen die Miete war über
Jahrzehnte subventioniert lag bei 6 Euro
kalt nun läuft die Preisbindung für ca
1200 Wohnungen aus leider ist halt so
gesetzlich dass sie nach bestimmten
Jahren eben rausfallen damit dann der
Eigentümer daraus gewinnen
erwirtschaften kann auch Frau mihalic
sorgt sich obwohl in Berlin gerade ein
mietenstopp für städtische Wohnungen
verkündet wurde aber nur für ein Jahr
wie hunderte ihrer Nachbarn bekam sie
Post ab nächstem Jahr leben sie nicht
mehr in einer Sozialwohnung
sozialen Wohnungsbau haben wir uns
durchaus sicher gefühlt was die Miete
und das Drumherum angeht aber jetzt ja
schon die Angst dass jetzt nur noch auf
gewinnen ausgelegt wird Neukölln hier
baut eine Investor neue Wohnungen ein
dritte Sozialwohnungen bei den rasanten
Preis- und Zinssteigerungen nun mit
Verlusten die private Bauwirtschaft tut
sich schwer mit dem Sozialbau wenn wir
im Grundstück kaufen und ein Haus drauf
bauen dann brauchen wir 12 Euro 10 bis
12 Euro Miete um die Kosten zu decken
und einigermaßen wirtschaftliches
herzustellen wenn wir für sechs Euro 50
vermieten müssen dann müssen wir
zwangsläufig die anderen Wohnung für 15
16 17 Euro vermieten um die 6,50€ zu
spons Sponsoren das ist ein krankes
System das funktioniert so nicht dabei
sollten in Berlin 5000 neue
Sozialwohnungen pro Jahr entstehen
1400 sind es letztes Jahr nur geworden
um das bauklima zu verbessern gibt es
nun neue Förderbedingungen 750 Millionen
Euro stehen jetzt zur Verfügung wir
bieten 30 Prozent in tilgungsverzicht an
das ist sehr attraktiv ich kann alle
Bauherr nur am Montag sich das
anzuschauen und die ist jetzt wenige
Wochen auf dem Markt und schon sind 1700
Wohnungen beantragt Sozialwohnungen
beantragt zu fördern
mihalic ist bereits am Limit Hilfspakete
und mietenstopp für sie nur ein Aufschub
Ihres Problems wohin wenn selbst das
Leben hier am Stadtrand zu teuer wird
wir haben uns tatsächlich natürlich auch
umgeschaut auf dem Wohnungsmarkt und
haben nach alternativen geschaut aber in
der aktuellen Entwicklung kann man sich
die halt einfach nicht leisten
[Musik]
ob große Stadt oder auf dem Land die
Probleme sind die gleichen Gau-Algesheim
in der Nähe von Mainz seit den 70er 80er
Jahren gibt es hier 120 Sozialwohnungen
doch vor kurzem hat er Besitzer ein
Immobilienkonzern die Blogs an einen
Investor verkauft jetzt machen sich
viele Bewohner Sorgen um ihre Zukunft
denn die Preisbindung für die
Sozialwohnungen läuft in drei Jahren aus
Stefan Schumacher sucht in letzter Zeit
häufig das Gespräch mit seiner Nachbarin
[Musik]
das worum sich alles dreht ist die Frage
können Sie sich die Mieten bald nicht
mehr leisten mir war dann schon
irgendwie sehr unwohl weil ich
gesagt habe hier das sind ja hier
eigentlich Sozialwohnungen also es geht
hier eigentlich um einen politisch
geschützten Bereich und der soll jetzt
plötzlich dazu dienen dass eine
Profitmaximierung stattfindet das
passiert das passt ja irgendwie nicht
zusammen denn der Investor will die
Wohnungen an Kapitalanleger
weiterverkaufen und das macht den
Mitarbeiter eines bioladens und der
Verkäuferin Angst und dann hatte ich
wochenlang schlaflose Nächte
Essstörung schlaflose Nächte
Kopfschmerzen Blutdruck hoch Blutdruck
und so weiter und so fort weil der
Gedanke ist mir durch den Kopf gegangen
mir wurde der Boden unter den Füßen
genommen
ein Gefühl das wohl alle rund 300 Meter
der Wohnanlage Teilen er sei wütend
fühle sich hilflos sagt der
Bürgermeister von Gau-Algesheim denn die
Gemeinde kann die 120 Sozialwohnungen
nicht ersetzen sie will zwar hier neue
günstigere Wohnungen schaffen darunter
aber nur vier bis fünf Sozialwohnungen
ich habe den wieder hier versprochen
dass alle die in wirtschaftlich nicht so
starken Verhältnissen leben dass die
städtische Wohnungen bekommen wenn diese
frei werden aber jetzt ist es natürlich
so dass nicht alle Wochen eine
städtische Wohnung frei wird jetzt
zahlen die Mieter hier 5,50€ pro
Quadratmeter nach Ende der Preisbindung
kann die Miete alle drei Jahre erhöht
werden bis zur Vergleichsmiete von
Gau-Algesheim und die liegt jetzt schon
bei über 12 Euro
Bernadette unzner lebt seit 35 Jahren
hier ihre Wohnung ist ein fester Teil
ihres Lebens aber jetzt fragt sie sich
jeden Tag wie lange noch